And we're live,
it's going on.
Where did you sleep?
Well last night.
I did.
I didn't sleep that badly.
I mean,
hotels are a tough thing.
Um,
and we actually know the science that
I'm one half of your brain will actually
not sleep as deeply than the other when
you're sleeping in a,
an unusual room,
like a hotel room.
Really,
that's what fucks me up when I'm on the
road,
you know,
I'll do three different hotels in a week
because I'll do like a Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
like with gigs and then by the time
Sunday rolls around,
I'm a mess in rough shape.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
And it's a union.
It's a threat detection thing.
I mean if you look at other species,
they can do this much more impressively
than we can.
So dolphins or any sort of sea dwelling
memo can actually sleep with half a
brain.
So one half of that brain goes into deep
sleep.
The other half is wide awake.
That's how people,
the DMV do it.
Those people that work at the department
of motor vehicles,
they're there.
They work half asleep.
You ever meet him?
I haven't.
No.
Just teasing the DMV.
Listening.
Going fuck you man.
Next time you come in and get your
license renewed.
That was my next NIH grant.
I think looking at the DMV and sleep.
But yeah,
we ESA workers.
Same thing,
same,
same type of human that I've come across
them too.
I'm just kidding.
Fuckers.
Relax.
Um,
so when you're in a hotel room,
what is happening that you're half.
Your brain is not really sleeping.
Yeah.
So there's different stages of sleep.
There are two principle types.
One is non rapid eye movement sleep or
non rem sleep.
The other is rem sleep,
which is also known as dream sleep and
non rapid eye movement.
Sleep is further divided into four
separate stages,
which are unimaginatively called stages
one through four were a creative bunch
is easy to remember that it is true,
but I think it's also a low Iq,
but it's the deep stages of sleep.
Three and four of that non rapid eye
movement.
That's where a lot of sort of body
replenishment takes place.
Grief,
the cardiovascular system,
metabolism,
all of those good things,
but that's the deep sleep that one half
of your brain will resist going into
when you're sleeping in a foreign
environment.
So it stays in this kind of lighter
stage,
almost like a threat detection system.
And you can imagine why,
you know,
it's an unusual context,
evolutionarily.
It would make a lot of sense to just
have that sort of on guard one half of
the brain that makes so much sense.
And that really for me,
it fills in the blanks of like why even
if I get,
you know,
seven,
eight hour sleep on the road,
I'm still kind of just out of it.
Yeah.
And that's in fact,
probably one of the,
I think the most impressive parts of new
research on sleep.
It's not just about quantity,
it's also about quality and quality can
be as detrimental if you don't get it as
a reduction in total quality.
I mean both are essential,
but I think it speaks exactly to your
point.
You just don't feel like it's a
refreshing sort of deep sleep.
Um,
yeah,
it feels totally different.
Um,
it just feels like,
I guess I would say it feels like half
asleep.
Yeah,
me too.
It's really kind of out does feel.
One of the things that I noticed,
I did this thing with my friends called
sober October where we,
um,
didn't smoke any pot or do any,
no drinking at all,
nothing for a month.
And when I did it,
one of the things I found was that after
about,
I don't know how many days,
but it was noticeable that I would have
these incredibly vivid dreams.
And then I had read that marijuana does
something to suppress heavy rem sleep.
Like what,
what,
what is happening there?
Yeah.
So both of those chemicals,
both of which are used as a sleep aid,
alcohol and marijuana are actually very
good at blocking your dream sleep,
your rapid eye movement,
sleep.
And so what happens is that the brain is
quite clever in this regard.
It builds up a clock counter of how much
dream sleep you should have had but have
not been getting.
And it starts to develop this increasing
appetite and hunger for dream sleep.
So that finally,
when the alcohol actually gets out of
your system,
sober October,
the love of the day,
that's all of a sudden where you get
what's called a rem sleep rebound
effect,
where you not only get the normal amount
of rem sleep that you would normally
have,
you get that,
plus the brain tries to get back some of
that dream sleep that it's been losing
over the past maybe 11 months.
Um,
so you get this 20 years.
I didn't want to make any assumptions of
uh,
so,
um,
so you get this rem sleep rebounded
effect and that's where you have these
really intense dream sleep.
Um,
situations.
It's the same reason that people,
they'll say like,
I had a bit too much to drink last
night.
Maybe it was a Friday or Saturday.
They sleep in late.
They say,
I just had these crazy dreams.
What happens there is a kind of an acute
version where the alcohol is swilling
around in your system and after about
six hours,
your liver and your kidneys to finally
excrete it,
all of the alcohol and your brain has
been deprived of dream sleep for that
first six hours.
So then it feast in the last couple of
hours and that's why you have these
really bizarre dreams after you've been
drinking a little bit too much.
Oh Wow.
So what is happening with marijuana
though specifically?
Do you know?
Yeah,
so marijuana,
it does help.
People will help it.
It puts people to sleep quicker.
Although I think the question is whether
it's really naturalistic sleep or not,
that they go into.
Certainly with alcohol,
it's not that nightcap idea is a
misnomer.
Alcohol will actually will.
It's a form of drugs that we call the
sedatives and sedation is not sleep.
It's very different,
but we often mistake one for the other.
Marijuana seems to act in a
physiologically for a different way.
It doesn't target the same receptors in
the brain,
so it's unclear with the speed with
which you fall asleep after having a
session with marijuana is actually
natural sleep.
Let's assume it is the problem,
however.
Is that it?
Then we'll start to disrupt rem sleep.
It will start to block the process.
We think perhaps at the level of the
brainstem,
which is where these two types of sleep,
non rem and rem sleep will actually get
sort of worked out.
That's where marijuana may actually
impact dream sleep and shut it down and
block it.
Have there been any studies on chronic
marijuana smokers,
like those,
uh,
dawn to dusk type characters that just
are constantly high?
Like what happens to their brain from
not because they must never hit rem
sleep.
Yeah.
So people haven't looked at marijuana.
They have looked at alcohol though.
Exactly that.
So what happens is if you look at
alcoholics,
they will have some thing often when
they come off alcohol,
something called Delirium Tremens,
which is where sort of Dt I'm there.
What happens is that the alcohol has
been blocking dream sleep for so long
and the pressure for dream sleep has
built up so powerfully in the brain.
It actually just spills over into
wakefulness and so the brain just says,
look,
okay,
if I'm not going to get this dream sleep
whilst you're asleep,
I'm just going to take it whilst you're
awake,
and so you start to essentially dream
while you're awake.
It's this sort of collision of two
states of consciousness,
so you get delirium.
Wow.
I always thought the dts.
We're detoxing other one.
Someone said someone's going through the
dts.
Okay.
Yeah.
So it's delirium.
Tremor,
yeah.
Delirium.
Tremens.
Yeah.
Sort of.
So what,
like what is going on with them when
this is happening.
So if they are going through this
delirium during the day,
while they're conscious,
what's physiologically happening?
So it's almost as though the veil of rem
sleep gets pulled over the waking brain
as it were.
So you have this mixed state of
consciousness that you can pick up with
brain wave recordings and he just tells
me,
I mean in some ways how necessary sleep
must be if that's the length that the
brain will go to to get that which it's
been missing,
just shows you why,
you know,
it took mother nature three point 6
million years to put this thing called
anytown asleep necessity in place and
we've come along and within the space of
100 years we've locked up almost 20
percent of that.
If you look at the data,
wow,
really know so many people take pride in
that too.
I don't need eight hour sleep.
I got three.
I'm good,
ready to go kick ass and dominate the
world.
This sort of like sleep,
machismo attitude.
There is a lot of that,
right?
Yeah.
Baby.
Alex Lee.
Well,
I mean you'd be glad to know that.
Then you know,
men who sleep five to six hours a night,
we'll have a level of testosterone which
is that of someone 10 years their
senior.
So lack of sleep will age.
You buy a decade in terms of that
particular aspect
of wellness for realty,
neck,
muscle strength.
Sexual performance.
Yeah.
Credible.
Wow.
We had a woman on the podcast,
her name is Courtney [inaudible],
Walter and cheese,
a ultra marathon runner.
And she ran a.
she's a real freak.
I mean,
like an incredible athlete.
She ran this thing called the Moab to
40.
It's 238 miles through the Moab
Mountains and she did it 22 miles faster
than the second place man.
So she won it by like a whopping,
I think it was 10 hours,
10 hours ahead of the second place
winner.
And she slept one minute,
one minute the entire time.
She tried to lie.
This is over three days.
I think it took her less than three
days.
I think it took her like two days.
Um,
she slept for one minute during the
entire time,
but she tried to lie down.
She,
she said she laid down for a few minutes
but she couldn't fall asleep.
And then she wound up actually just
taking one minute and going to sleep.
And she said that one minute was like
one of the most intense restful minutes
after that minute is over,
she was woken up because she told her
partner running partner to wake her up
at a minute and she's like,
how long did you let me sleep?
And he was like,
one minute.
She was like,
wow,
I feel great,
let's go.
But she was saying that she hallucinates
and that she starts seeing like rabbits
or talking to her and she sees things
that aren't there and like mystical
beings and stuff.
She said it's really freaky,
but she knows that she's hallucinating
because she's done this.
She's done a bunch of an ultra marathon.
So she just keeps going.
She just keeps going and she's like
saying hi to rabbits there talking to
her and stuff.
Yeah,
I mean you see these reports too.
I mean this is a race of cycling,
race of thing.
His bike across America just got to go
from east coast to west coast in a
shorter time as possible.
And that exactly what they do too.
It's all about managing how little sleep
that you get.
And they will explain these wild
hallucinogenic experiences on the bike.
If you look at world records for people
who have tried to sort of go without
sleep.
And one of the most famous examples is a
radio disc jockey called Peter trip back
in the,
um,
it was back in the sort of sixties,
fifties,
sixties.
And he tried to break the world record.
He went eight days straight.
Um,
and yeah,
no sleep.
Yeah,
he was broadcasting from time square.
He would do is show the.
And you know,
the scientists,
the psychiatrist said,
look,
this is a very bad idea based on what we
know,
please don't do it.
And he said,
I'm going to do it anyway.
And then the scientists being a good
scientist,
they said,
great,
do you mind if we study here because
it'd be a great paper to sort of,
you know,
to write up.
And they tracked him.
And by day three he was having Florid
delusions and hallucinations.
He was seeing spiders in his shoes.
He became desperately paranoid.
He started to think that people were
trying to poison him in his food.
One point,
it was the middle of winter,
some guys came in with sort of these
barriers.
New York winter came in with these big
jackets.
He thought it was the secret service
coming to get him and he ran out into
the road,
you know,
these are strange,
but so we know that that same profile of
just starting to become psychotic,
which is essentially what happens
naturally when you dream that you are,
I mean all of us here,
you know,
as long as we slept last night,
became flagrantly psychotic when we went
into dream sleep because you start to
see things which are not there.
So you hallucinate,
you believe things that couldn't
possibly be true.
So you're delusional.
You get confused about time,
place and person.
So you're suffering from disorientation.
You have wildly fluctuating emotions.
Something that psychiatrist called being
sort of effectively label.
And then how wonderful.
We both woke up this morning and we
forgot most if not all of that dream
experience.
So,
uh,
suffering from Amnesia,
what is happening when you're having
these hallucinogenic experiences?
Like what are the chemicals that are
causing.
Do we know?
We do.
Yeah.
And so we've done some of these studies
where we put people into brain scanners,
we let them fall asleep,
and then we see what happens within the
brain,
which parts of the brain of switching on
which parts of the brain of switching
off when you go into rem sleep,
firstly some parts of your brain become
30 percent more active than when you're
awake.
So you know,
we think of sleep as this sort of,
you know,
static,
passive state where everything just kind
of drops down in terms of activity.
Quite the contrary.
But what's also interesting is that not
all parts of the brain ramp up when you
go into rem sleep,
visual parts of the brain,
increased motor parts of the brain,
increase emotional centers and memory
centers.
They all increase,
but the part of the brain that bucks the
trend and goes in the opposite direction
is the part of the brain that we call
the prefrontal cortex.
This sort of CEO of the brain that's
very good at rational,
logical thinking.
That parts of the part of the brain gets
shut off.
So it's almost as though you know the,
the prison guards are gone and everyone
runs a mark because there's no
controller in place.
And so we know sort of from the patterns
of brain activity,
why you become sort of so visual.
You see things,
why you have motor kinesthetic activity,
why things feel so emotional,
but also why things seem utterly
illogical and irrational because your
frontal brain,
the thing that makes us most human,
you can say goodbye to that for the rest
of dream sleep.
So there's no driver.
Yeah.
Now why do we forget?
Why do we forget those dreams?
Because I
wake up and I am sure that I'm going to
remember these dreams and sometimes I
do.
Sometimes our member and I don't think I
really remember them.
I think what it is is very much like you
ever hear someone talk about a memory
from a long time ago.
I used to think that people actually
remembered things from a long time ago,
but now what I as Dave remember
remembering it,
I think they remember talking about it.
They remember how they described it and
then they sort of remember that and
repeat it and in their mind convinced
themselves that that's what happened
because I've heard people tell stories
about the past and they're,
they vary wildly from what is absolutely
true.
Like,
like factual.
You could check it,
you could research it,
you know what the facts are,
but in their mind it's very different
and I think that it's entirely possible
that what people are doing is
remembering the recollection of these
memories and how they told them and then
also sort of people elaborate things and
make themselves look better or make the
situation look more dramatic.
But with dreams that doesn't make any
sense.
So I was always trying to figure out
like what is it about a dream where
sometimes I can remember the dream and
sometimes it's so vivid when I wake up,
I'm like,
holy shit,
that was crazy.
What a dream.
And then I forget it 20 minutes later.
Great.
What is that soup firstly?
I mean,
one theory of dreaming is that it's just
simply a reconstruction when you wake
up.
So you have these fragments of activity
and what your cortex does when it wakes
up is what your cortex is designed to do
when you're awake normally,
which is try to package everything,
can make a good story,
make logical fit out of the world.
That's one theory.
I don't believe that though.
Um,
your,
your point is a really interesting one.
Do I remember my dreams?
Um,
that doesn't necessarily mean I forget
my dreams.
And what I mean by that is accessibility
versus availability.
So if you haven't had that experience
where you've woken up,
you thought I was definitely dreaming,
I can't quite grab it.
You know,
it just and it's gone.
And then two days later you're in the
shower,
you sort of washing yourself,
you see a bottle of shampoo,
you see the label,
and it just triggers the unlocking of
that dream memory and it sort of comes
flooding back or someone says something
to you and you think,
oh,
that was the dream.
What that tells me as a brain scientist
is that the memory is there.
It's preserved,
it's available.
But what happens when most of the time
when we wake up is that we lose the Ip
address to the memory,
so it's present,
but it's not consciously accessible,
available,
not accessible.
If that's true,
what it means is that this type of
information we know can have
nonconscious impacts on our behavior all
the time.
It's great brain science about this
nonconscious memory processing.
It's possible that we store every one of
our dreams.
We just don't consciously have
accessibility to it.
But nevertheless it's changing how we
behave,
how we feel each and every day.
No evidence for it to theory.
I'm still wanting to test.
But that's possible too.
And it's only that anecdote where I can
think.
I just don't remember the dream.
I forgotten it.
I don't.
That may be true.
It may still be there.
I just need to find
keys to sort of access that memory.
What's stunning to me is how quickly the
dream evaporates.
The memory of the dream or in relation
to an actual experience.
Like if we went outside and we saw some
lady walk up to some guy and kick him in
the balls,
we'd be like,
whoa.
We would remember that and that you
needed to be able to tell your friends
like,
yeah,
some lady just randomly walked as some
guy and kicked him in the balls.
Like we would remember that and you'd
remember it 10 minutes later you'd
member in an hour you'd remembered.
Yes.
Next day you'd be telling your friends.
Yeah,
she just walked right up to him.
I remember it like it was yesterday
because it was right,
but a dream it can be 10 minutes ago and
you wake up and dude it was King Kong
and he was.
He was swinging from my ceiling and
somehow or another they fit in the room,
but the room got bigger and you have
these crazy dreams and then 20 minutes
later you forget all of it.
Like what is happening there?
So one,
one current explanation is that the
chemistry of the brain when you go into
dream sleep is radically different.
Yeah.
So one of the chemicals called
noradrenaline in the brain,
which downstairs in the body it's sister
chemical,
is called adrenaline.
Noradrenaline actually plummets to the
lowest level.
It's actually,
it's a stress chemical in the brain or
to one of them that get shut off during
dream sleep,
which has been.
If you're panicking like what if you
fall off a building?
Well,
what's interesting is that that chemical
is low wealth.
You're having that dream,
but when you wake up from those and some
people often wake up,
that's when you have the spike of
origin,
so it's still low when you're in dream
sleep,
but there's another chemical that goes
in the opposite direction.
It's called acid tile.
Coleen.
It's the chemical that is actually an
altered in Alzheimer's disease and these
two chemicals will change essentially
the input output direction of
information flow into the memory centers
of the brain center.
Sense
excuse people take that as a nootropic
they do.
Yeah.
That's actually an Alpha brain when when
you take that,
it's has been clinically proven to
enhance memory,
especially verbal memory and
recollection of words and things like
that.
That's right.
So that's happening while your sleeping
well,
so you're in rem sleep,
but what may be happening,
our current model is if you sort of
build these neural models to sort of
mimic dreaming,
it may be that during dreaming it's
principally about the outflow of
information to generate dreams and in
fact the chemical profile is
oppositional to input which is about
saving.
So it's about sort of pumping out
information rather than committing
information.
And so when you come out of a dream
sleep,
you still get this sort of lingering
after sort of taste of chemistry as it
were in the brain.
That means that the dreaming brain is
more programmed to be outputting a
narrative and an experience rather than
actually committing it to memory,
which is the opposite direction.
That makes sense.
It
does make sense.
Um,
how aware are you of dimethyltryptamine?
I'm somewhat aware of it scientifically.
Not,
not,
not personally.
Yeah.
I'm one of the things about psychedelic
experiences with dimethyltryptamine.
First of all,
it's endogenous.
You,
your brain produces it,
your lungs,
your liver produce it.
But when you have a dmt experience after
it's over,
the memory fades very rapidly and it
seems just like a dream in that regard.
We're while while you're having it,
what's bizarre is that you're having it
while you're awake and then after you
have it within 10,
20 minutes,
it is just like a dream that you can't
remember.
It's a very.
I remember like little flashes of
experiences that I've had and there's
been a lot of speculation that that's
one of the things that you're
experiencing while you're in heavy rem
sleep and that could be responsible for
the crazy visuals that you have.
That seemed so vivid.
I mean there's been times where I've had
dreams where I was 100 percent convinced
that I was awake and then something
happened.
Like I do this thing sometimes where
I'll.
If I do it consciously a lot.
I think I saw in one of those wacky
movies like what the bleep do we know?
I think I saw it in that when you walk
up to a door,
as you're walking through the door,
you knock on the side of the door and
go,
am I awake?
Nope,
not awake,
or am I asleep?
Rather?
Yeah,
no,
I'm not asleep because I'm not going to
the door.
Well,
I did that in my hand was just like
going right through the wall and I'm
like,
oh,
I'm sleeping.
And then I woke up and there was like
woo.
But the feeling that I had while I was
in that dream,
it was so vivid.
I mean everything seemed so real.
Like what could possibly be causing me
to construct this artificial reality in
my mind that at the moment at least was
indistinguishable from the reality that
experience right now.
And I'm assuming because I just knocked
on the table that I'm awake.
Yeah.
I really hope I'm not just a fictive
character in your dreams.
Maybe we're sharing a dream yet very
inception,
like possible,
not based on the science so far.
Um,
but I think you know,
what you're speaking about,
there really is almost why would,
why would mother nature create this
thing called the dream experience?
You know,
what would be the function of
essentially every night going into what
sums up to be about two total hours of
virtual reality experience and testing.
One possibility which is deeply
unsatisfying is that it's just a
byproduct.
It's just Epi,
phenomenal that when your brain goes
into this thing called rem sleep and all
of the different patterns of brain
activity that we described,
an offshoot is this thing that we call
dreaming in the same way that a light
bulb,
the reason that we construct the
apparatus that's a light bulb is to
produce light.
But when you produce light in that way,
you also produce heat.
It was never the function of the light
bulb.
It's just what happens when you produce
light in that way may be dreaming is
just sort of the heat of rem sleep and
rem sleep serves lots of other
functions.
But wow,
that doesn't feel to me right though.
Why?
Well,
firstly,
I think it's probably additionally
metabolically demanding to have dreams
in addition to this thing called rem
sleep and whenever mother nature burns
calories,
it's usually for a reason because
they're so precious.
That's a good point.
That makes sense too.
Yeah.
I read some article about the lack of
rem sleep with marijuana users and it
was trying to say,
and it made me super skeptical even as a
pot smoker,
it was trying to say that it's not bad
for you because what it's essentially
doing is bypassing the rem sleep and
going directly into the deep sleep and
then it's helping you in that regard.
Does that make sense to you?
It doesn't make sense as a
neuroscientist.
He says nay,
you fucking stoners.
Obviously.
I'm just so deeply unpopular,
you know,
I'm telling you
don't smoke pot,
stay away from alcohol,
you know,
apart from a general personality,
which is dislikable.
This doesn't help me.
Definitely not dislikable,
but I don't think you're saying anything
wrong.
I think um,
I think marijuana,
like most things is best used in
moderation.
And one thing that I got out of the
sober October thing wasn't just that.
It's fascinating to see the dreams,
like just ramp up and get crazy.
But also that when you take a few days
off and then smoke a little pot,
the pot actually has more of an impact.
In fact,
one of my favorite psychedelic authors
and lectures,
the late great Terence Mckenna,
his advice was to not do marijuana for
long periods of time and then do as much
as you could stand.
And he was a,
you know,
a real psychedelic adventure in his
thought was to really get the benefit
out of marijuana.
It's not something that should be used
daily and recreate recreationally.
It should be used as a psychedelic
sacrament.
Not should be because he actually did
smell pot pretty rarely read pretty
regularly rather.
But his thought was if you really want
to get the full impact of it,
you shouldn't be accustomed to it.
And when you're accustomed to it,
you build up a tolerance to it and it
doesn't have the same impact.
Like it's that thing.
I don't know if you've ever been around
pot smokers,
but when someone doesn't smoke pot and
then they get talked into smoking pot
with some pot smokers,
it's always a terrible idea.
You got a bunch of people with super
high tolerances and some poor person
that doesn't have any tolerance and they
just,
they just get taken down a tornado,
rabbit whole journey into their child,
zero to 60 and so paranoid and thinking
about everything and freaking out all
these sensations and they just never
experienced before.
But,
uh,
the,
the idea that you could bypass rem sleep
and go straight into the deep sleep,
that doesn't make any sense to you.
No,
it doesn't.
And what we've learned over the past 30
or 40 years is all stages of sleep are
important.
You know,
when you think about sleep as a state,
it makes no sense.
You know,
first the,
your vulnerable to predation.
You're not finding food,
you're not finding a mate,
you're not reproducing,
you're not caring for your young on any
one of those grounds.
Sleep should have been strongly selected
against as a collective.
I mean it,
it's,
it's almost idiotic.
If sleep does not serve an absolutely
vital function,
it is the biggest mistake,
the evolutionary process ever made,
and that counts for all of the stages of
sleep too.
Again,
Mother Nature wouldn't waste time
putting you into a state that wasn't
necessary.
And what we've discovered is that all of
those different stages of sleep that we
spoke about all have unique and separate
functions.
So you can't short change any one of
them.
You don't need to bias towards one and
try and sort of,
you know,
play Kate,
the other,
you know,
evolution is,
has taken a long time to get the
blueprint accurately correct for each
physiological individual.
I wouldn't play around with it and think
that you're smarter than that process.
When I read it,
I felt like it was a justification for
smoking pot.
Like,
man,
you're just getting deeper sleep,
man.
You don't need that rem sleep.
You're passing it up,
man.
You just go right into the deep,
heavy,
necessary sleep.
Oh,
contra contrary potheads.
Um,
so what is happening to the body during
rem sleep that's so critical that one
particular aspect of sleep.
So firstly,
in the body,
the your cardiovascular system seems to
do something quite strange.
It goes through periods of dramatic
acceleration and then dramatic
deceleration during,
during rem sleep.
Quite unpredictable too.
We also know that during rem sleep,
your brain power analyzes your body so
that your mind can dream safely.
So wow,
I mean,
and that makes a lot of sense.
If you're thinking that you're,
you know,
this world champion mixed martial arts
person and it's in the middle of the
night,
you're not,
it's dark.
You can't see.
You're not perceiving or outside world,
you're going to get popped out of the
gene pool very quickly if you start
acting out that experience.
So there is a barrier in place that
mother nature locks you down in
incarceration,
muscling,
customer coloration.
That's crazy that you say that because
when I was fighting,
when I was young,
I would wake up throwing kicks.
I would kick in the middle of the night.
I would do it all the time.
I'd be sleeping and I just,
I would move and throw a kick in the
middle of the night and I remember
waking me up like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
And then I to go back to sleep again.
But I was obviously dreaming about
competing.
Do you actually remember this when you
woke up,
did you remember dreaming at that point
or did you just have no recollection of
anything going on at that point?
I believe I had a recollection.
It's been a long time,
but I believe I had a recollection.
I'm like,
I would be like in bed with my
girlfriend would wake her up too,
you know,
because I just don't like.
I wouldn't throw a full kick but my body
would move.
Like I was going to,
you know,
like I would turn my hips and my leg
would extend.
It was my body was,
it was I,
I've,
I attributed to the,
the idea that it's so extreme,
like the activity of fighting is so
extreme that my brain had kind of like
hyper charged itself to compete at this
very high level,
you know,
and that this was so unusual that it
was,
it was almost at red alert all the time
and maybe even trying to work out
patterns while I was sleeping.
That's exactly the evidence that we have
now.
So for things like
skills or even rats running around a
maze where they will learn specific sort
of navigational pathways and even
skilled motor movements.
What you can do is you can place these
electrodes into census of the,
of the brain.
We,
we work in my sleep,
sleep center works on humans,
but other people have done these studies
in rats and you implant electrodes and
you measure the brain cells firing as
the rat is running around the maze.
And let's say that you can sort of play
little tones for each brain cell.
So they're running around the maze and
and you can listen to the brain cells to
learning
the signature of that may so it goes,
but bup,
bup,
bup.
But what was amazing is that when you
let those rats sleep,
but you keep listening to the brain,
what you hear is as if the brain is
actually an infected is it's replaying
the exact same sequence.
They memory sequence that it was
learning whilst it was awake,
it's replaying,
but at a speed that is 20 times faster.
So now we start to get into this
inception.
Weldon,
I don't mean to cause the scientific
data read that we're not sort of in that
territory,
but you know that notion of time
compression and time dilation that
Christopher Nolan played so well within
that movie.
We can see that at the level of brain
cell firing in rats as they're learning
these mazes.
And it comes back to what you're saying,
which is that the better that they
reversed those skilled memories,
when you wake them up and test them the
next day,
that predicts how much better they are.
In terms of their performance,
so it's not just that you learn,
you go to sleep and you replay and you
hit the save button on these new
memories.
You actually scoped out those memories
and you improve them.
And we've done studies with motor skill
learning critical for athletics,
performance and practice does not make
perfect practice with a night
of sleep is what makes perfect because
you come back the next day and you're 20
to 30 percent better in terms of your
skilled performance than where you were
at the end of your practice session the
day before.
Wow.
I mean sleep is the greatest legal
performance enhancing drug that most
people are probably neglecting in sport.
Wow.
And not just for your physical
performance,
but actually skill learning.
That's right.
Skill learning,
memory.
And then also,
you know,
downstairs in the body all over the
recuperative benefits.
Um,
and you can flip the coin by the way,
if you're getting six hours of sleep or
less,
your time to physical exhaustion drops
by up to 30 percent.
So you could spend all of your time
training for 10 round fight,
perfect condition.
But then I put you on six hours of sleep
the night before,
you're now going to be physically
exhausted by round seven rather than
around 10.
Wow.
But.
Well,
and that's a really hard thing for
fighters because they have a very
difficult time sleeping the night before
a big fight.
Yeah.
It's very,
very difficult because usually sit and.
Yep.
And I would imagine it's got to be.
I mean it's probably going to take a
huge,
a huge tournament is probably be a huge
benefit if they can somehow or another
bypass all that and just relax and learn
how to relax and learn how to actually
sleep.
I mean it's,
I think it's one of constantly trying to
hack the physiological system,
especially in elite sports these days
because you know,
small fractions of a percent of gain to
make a huge difference.
So that sounds like 30 percent.
That's a monster.
Huge.
Yeah.
I mean your time to sort of not just
physical exertion,
but you know,
the lactic acid builds up quicker.
The less and less that you sleep your
ability of the lungs to actually expire.
Carbon dioxide inhale,
oxygen decreases,
the less sleep that you have
so much sense.
Why?
Because when I was doing,
I was doing fear factor and I was doing
standup comedy and then I was also doing
another television show and I was doing
Jujitsu.
I never got eight hours sleep.
I'm mostly got four,
usually go for it and my cardio is
sucked.
It was terrible.
And I'd be like,
why is my cardio soccer workout so much?
Like that was probably what it was.
Yeah,
it's a huge part of that.
Now,
how many hours of sleep should you get?
Similar between?
It gives me somewhere between seven to
nine hours.
Um,
once you get below seven hours of sleep,
we can measure objective,
impermanent your
brain and your body.
I can show that in the last two days and
I can show it because I basically did
the same workout two days in a row.
Um,
the day before I had flown back from
Boston,
very tired.
I'm hiring out with my kids all day.
Went to get some sleep,
but then I had to do some stuff at like
2:00
in the morning.
And uh,
I just never really got good sleep.
And then my youngest daughter got up at
five,
she was crying and then eventually my
alarm went off at eight,
so my sleep was like three,
four hours.
It was all screwy and the night before
it was even less because I had flown and
I had to get up early for the flight and
I tried to sleep on the plane and I went
running and I felt like dog shit.
And then during the day I felt like dog
shit,
I just didn't have,
like as I was running,
I just didn't have any extra gear.
I was like,
I did it,
I pushed through it,
but then it was over.
It was like,
oh,
well last night,
last night I slept seven and a half
hours,
woke up today,
lifted weights,
ran,
felt great,
feel great.
Now,
like two days in difference.
I mean,
that's the difference.
The difference is one day I got real
sleep.
One day I did and I did the exact same
thing even more today I did,
I lifted weights today as well.
And I just feel great.
So I could see,
I could see it physiologically in the
difference in my performance in 24
hours.
Yeah,
and that's noticeable.
I mean we see that too.
You know,
your,
um,
your peak muscle strength,
your physical vertical jump height and
your peak running speed,
all of those things correlate with
sleep.
The less that you have,
the worst,
those outcomes are probably one of the
most surprising factors.
There was injury risk when they've
looked at athletes across a season and
they've just plotted how frequently will
they get injured and then they surveyed
them,
you know,
how much sleep are you getting?
And they bucketed them into sort of
people who are getting nine hours,
seven hours,
six,
five,
four,
and it's a perfect linear relationship.
The less sleep that you have hired your
injury risk,
so people getting nine hours versus five
hours,
there was almost a 60 percent increase
in probability of injury risk during a
season.
Do you attribute it
that to exhaustion or do you attribute
that to a lack of recovery from the
previous night's workout?
Is it a combination of those things?
Is it exhaustion causing you to miss
step perhaps and like twist an ankle or
turn a knee?
Yeah,
it's all of those things.
Even if you look at micro balance,
if you look at sort of the stability
muscles versus you know,
major muscles,
those stability muscles also fail when
you're not getting sufficient sleep.
And I think we often underestimate how
critical they are in sport performance,
particularly in terms of combating and
placating injury risk to see if you just
get someone on a stability ball,
you know,
sort of just dose them down with sleep
eight hours,
five hours,
three hours,
and just notice how those stability
muscles help you balance just the basic
act of balance that deteriorates
dramatically.
No wonder you're getting more or injury
risk.
Totally makes sense.
Now as a neuroscientist,
what do you attribute when,
when,
when people talk about visualization and
visualization is a,
it's a huge factor in improving
technical skills,
uh,
specifically more martial arts,
which is a,
I'm a big fan of obviously martial arts.
When you visualize people who visualize,
who sit down and like go over their
body,
going through the motions and doing
things,
those people perform better,
they better,
they,
um,
they learn quicker.
What do you attribute that to?
Do you think it's the same thing as
what's happening when you're sleeping?
Just maybe to a lesser extent.
I think it's to a lesser extent,
but people have done those studies where
they've looked at sort of whether you
actually physically practice,
let's say on a keyboard,
just because it's easier to sort of
managing the laboratory versus just
imagining sort of typing out that
sequence and just the act of physical
visualization,
of sort of imagination of that motor
skill.
It's about 50 percent as effective as
physically performing it too,
and it's 50 percent as effective.
What I mean there is in changing the
plastic connections within the brain to
even just visualization,
know passive play as it were still can
actually cause a rewiring of the brain
beneficially.
Wow.
You know,
learning techniques,
specifically martial arts techniques.
My good friend,
Eddie Bravo,
so world famous Jujitsu instructor,
he's,
he's always.
I'm comparing it to tying your shoe and
he said,
do you know how like when you were a
little kid and you're trying to figure
out how to tie your shoe,
it's an extremely difficult thing to do.
Like how do I do this?
And you put that down and you do loops.
Like I'm watching my seven year old
daughter go through that right now.
But now as a grown man,
when I tie my shoe,
I could just be talking to you.
Oh,
what?
Oh yeah,
we're going to go tomorrow and I'll do
it.
I don't.
I don't even know what I did.
If you tried to ask me to explain how I
tie my shoes,
I'd be like,
how do I tell her shit?
Like I don't even know how I do it
because it just.
I have it in there.
It just it.
And the idea with martial arts is you've
got to be.
All of your techniques have to be
automatic.
Someone extends the arm.
You instantly hook it and go into the
arm bar.
You know someone.
You have to have these paths like so
drilled in that you don't even know
you're doing them until it's over.
Yeah.
So automaticity is one of the things
that sleep actually accomplishes.
Yeah.
I was talking about those 20 to 30
percent benefits in motor skill
performance.
So we did some additional studies to
actually say,
well what,
how it,
how does sleep do that?
You know,
where in your skill performance to sleep
give you the benefit.
So you're right,
tying a shoelace,
you know,
even driving a car with stick,
at first it's just overwhelming.
It's so difficult to clutch it's gas
pedal,
you know,
it's good and now it's just second
nature.
You know,
it's shifted from conscious to
automatic,
from conscious and unconscious.
If you look at performance that is
conscious and not automatic,
it's usually very staccato.
It's this,
then it's that,
then it's that.
It's not fluid.
If you heard someone trying to sort of
play piano to begin with,
doesn't sound very fluid.
You know,
as someone who is a maestro,
it just flows out of them.
So we looked at this with skill
performance.
Again,
sort of a keyboard playing musicianship
and you learn and you learn,
you get better and let's see,
but you type a sequence that take four,
one,
three,
two,
four,
and people learn it,
but they have these problem points
throughout the sequence.
They go four,
one,
three,
two,
four,
one,
three,
two,
four as if it's as a sticking point to
the same thing with any skilled
performance in an in athletics and it's
the brain chunking things up.
A very long motor sequence gets chunked
up into small sort of digestible bites.
It's a good way to begin learning,
but it's not a way to create
automaticity.
At some point.
What you have to do is stitch all of
those things together and it just flows
like a sentence,
like a sentence.
Yeah,
like a piano piece,
like a,
you know,
a sequence of movements.
If you've got,
you know,
in martial arts you've got.
So what we found was that before sleep,
you've got these big problem points,
these gaps in your motor skill.
Learning sleep does not necessarily
improve the places where you're already
good.
Sleep is intelligent.
It goes in,
finds that problem,
point,
that friction point in your motor skill
sort of deficit and it smooths it out.
So you come back the next day and now
it's just four,
one,
three,
two,
four,
one,
three,
two,
four,
three.
It's automaticity and it's exactly what
you're describing,
you know,
speak to musicians.
They'll say,
I was playing,
I just couldn't get that piece the night
before.
And then I came back the next day and I
sat down and I could just play,
sleeps doing its work.
I've heard that too with problems and
that's why people say sleep on it.
Yeah.
You've never been told to stay awake on
a problem,
right?
I mean sometimes when you're about to go
to bed,
it's almost overwhelming.
You just can't concentrate on anything
else,
but this problem,
whatever it is.
And then you go to sleep and you wake up
in the morning like,
Eh,
that's all right.
Yeah,
it's going to be fun.
I got it.
I know what to do.
And sleep.
So there's lots of anecdotal evidence of
sleep inspired creativity and now the
shift to one of the benefits of
dreaming,
in fact,
it's during dream sleep,
when we take all of the information that
we've previously learned and we start to
collide it with all of the new
information that we've learned.
It's um,
I mean it's a little bit like group
therapy for memories,
you know,
everyone gets a name badge and you will
get to speak to each other and the brain
starts to seek out and test novel
connections and new associations.
So it's almost like informational
alchemy and you wake up the next morning
with a revised mind wide web that is now
capable of dividing,
you know,
incredible solutions to previously
impenetrable problems.
And lots of anecdotes.
You know,
Dmitri Mendeleev came up with the
periodic table of elements by way of
dream in spite insight,
you know,
talk about a Herculean task.
Take all of the elements in the known
universe and figure out a structure as
to how they all fit together.
Off you go,
his waking could not do
it.
His sleeping brain solved the problem.
And Einstein,
by the way,
this is Einstein was suggested to be a
short sleeper and we don't know if
that's true,
but even if he was,
he was a habitual Napa during the day.
I've got some great pictures of him on
his work bench and he used sleep
ruthlessly as a tool for creativity and
he would sit at his desk and he would
have a sort of pad of paper and a pencil
and he had a chair with arm rests and he
would pick up two steel ball bearings
and take a metal saucepan and turn it
upside down,
placed underneath the arm of the chair
and put the tool,
steel ball bearings in his hand and he
would rest back and he would start to
fall asleep and so we didn't fall too
far into sleep.
What would happen is at some point his
muscle tone would relax.
They would release the steel ball
bearings.
They would crash on the Saucepan,
wake him up,
and then he would write down all of the
creative ideas that he was.
Half isn't the half really in no one
day.
Yeah.
You're never told to sort of stay awake
and a problem,
and in every language that I've inquired
about today,
I'm French Swahili.
That phrase,
sleeping on a problem seems to exist,
which must mean that this benefit of
dream sleep transcends cultural
boundaries.
I should note.
I think it's important that the French,
the French translation is much closer to
you.
You sleep with a problem.
We,
the British,
you say you sleep on a problem,
the French,
you say you sleep with a problem.
I think it says so much about the
romantic difference between the British
and the French.
You know the Fed is trying to fuck
everything.
Fuck their problems.
No British passport,
but I won't either.
It's just a joke.
That's fascinating that Einstein figured
that out too,
that he literally had like a,
a whole routine that you had dropped
this ball and hit it bearing and wake up
and start writing like south will have
to be in the room watching Einstein to
that.
It must have been fascinating.
I'm sorry.
I said Einstein.
Edison.
I'm an idiot at changes everything.
That's probably the best medicine.
A thief though.
Didn't he steal everything from Tesla?
I think there's an argument to be made,
but I mean he has a lot to answer for by
the way,
in terms of the way that we're sleeping,
you know,
he electric,
he was the first person to electrify
society,
not necessarily create the light bulb,
but he really gave shifted us from a
point where now we controlled the night
in terms of illumination and we are a
dark deprived society in this modern era
and that's one of the things that are
keeping us awake at night.
A lack of darkness.
You're not just that,
but also our inability to see the stars
anymore.
The light pollution that we have at
night.
I think it's,
I think it's a giant shift in
perspective.
Like,
uh,
have you ever,
you ever been to a planetarium or.
I'm an observatory,
like one of those,
uh,
at night
there's a Keck observatory in Hawaii as
a place I try to go to every year.
And it's,
it's really stunning because it's very
high up.
I think the observatory is somewhat
somewhere more than 9,000
feet above sea level.
And then I think you go even further and
then they have the telescopes,
but you go to visit our center and you
go to the visitor center.
They have some telescope set up,
but it's huge actually drive through the
clouds.
So as you're driving up this mountain,
we were bummed out.
We're like,
oh,
it's cloudy.
We might not be able to see anything.
And then you drive through the clouds
and then we need to get through the
clouds.
You're like,
Holy Shit.
And you feel like you're on a spaceship
flying through space.
And this is what our ancestors saw every
night when they went to sleep with a
clear sky,
they saw all the stars.
They saw the full milky way like this.
And the way the big island has set up,
they use diffused lighting all over the
island because of the Keck observatory.
So you don't have the same level of
light pollution that you have when
you're in a normal city like Los
Angeles,
which is terrible.
I mean the La,
if you look up you see like one or two
stars because everything's lit up.
It's crazy bright that I think that
perspective is,
that's a giant factor in the way human
beings look at their relationship with
the universe,
but I think that also just the light
everywhere,
constant light everywhere.
It's got to be a big factor in why
people sleep so little,
right?
Yep.
We know it is now.
I mean,
these studies have been done.
The first part is the external light,
which is,
you know,
street lighting,
even if you've got curtains that can
still bleed through,
but then when you come into the home,
know the invasion of light into the home
by way of technology has been a big
problem.
People are looking at their phones
before they go to,
well first of the year,
I mean the incandescent light bulb sort
of was the start of it and light bulbs
can suppress a hormone that's called
Melatonin is the hormone of darkness and
it tells your brain when it's dark and
when it's time to sleep,
but then you add into that screen usage
and they've done studies where,
for example,
um,
you know,
one hour of ipad reading versus just one
hour of reading on a book,
you know,
in dim light,
that one hour of ipad reading firstly
delayed the release of this critical
darkness hormone called Melatonin by
about three hours.
So if you read on your ipad for an hour
here in California,
your Melatonin peak is not going to
arrive.
I mean somewhere in Hawaii time,
in fact,
it's three hours delayed.
Wow.
It's 50 percent less in terms of its
peak.
And furthermore,
you don't get the same amount of rem
sleep and when you wake up the next
morning,
you don't feel refreshed or restored by
your sleep.
Those studies have been done to wow,
what should someone do
if they have a hard time sleeping?
Like say if you're a person who has
insomnia,
you have a hard time getting,
getting to bed and you have a hard time
staying asleep.
When you wake up,
you can't go back to bed.
Are there other strategies?
There are.
I mean,
I think for most people that are five
things that you can do just out the gate
to get better sleep regularity is
probably the most important thing I can
tell you.
Go to bed at the same time,
wake up at the same time,
no matter whether it's the weekend.
Weekday regularity is key.
We've spoken about light.
For example,
when you in the last hour before bed,
tried to stay away from screens but also
just switch off half the lights in the
house.
You'd be surprised at how soporific that
is.
It really starts to sort of make you
feel a bit more drowsy.
They done some great studies where they
would take people out into the rockies,
no electric light,
no electricity whatsoever,
and they started to go to bed two hours
earlier than the acclaimed natural
bedtime wasn't just because they didn't
have anything necessarily to do.
It was that their Melatonin was rising,
you know,
two hours earlier.
So keep it dark.
The third is probably keep it cool.
Your brain actually needs to drop its
temperature by about two to three
degrees Fahrenheit to initiate sleep.
And that's the reason that you will
always find it easier to fall asleep in
a room that's too cold than too hot.
I've seen people use cold pads.
Casinos,
are you sleep on these cold pads?
What do you think of those?
Yeah,
I mean the evidence is pretty good that
cooling the body actually works.
They've,
um,
you know,
in the book I write about a series of
studies where they had people in it.
It's almost like a wet suit,
but it has all of these veins running
through it.
And they could actually perfuse warm or
cold water into any part of the body,
hands core of the body,
feet,
and so you could exquisitely manipulate
the temperature of any part of the body
and what they found is that they could
effectively cool the body down and it
instantaneously made people fall asleep
faster and it gave them deeper,
deep,
non rem sleep,
that sort of restorative sleep for the
body so you can even look at studies
where people sleep semi naked and that
also seems to improve their sleep and
they get a little bit more deep sleep
too.
So cold is better.
The paradox here though is that you need
to warm your feet and your hands to kind
of charm the blood away from your core
out to the surface and radiate that
heat.
Really should go to sleep with socks and
gloves on.
Yeah.
Or better.
Still have a hot bath and evidence here
to that.
I discussed where people say,
you know,
I get out of a hot bath.
I feel nice and toasty and relaxed and
that's why I fall asleep.
It's the opposite.
When you get into a bath,
you get vasodilation,
all you sort of get rosy cheeks,
red skin,
all of the blood rushes to the surface.
You get out of the bath and you have
this massive thermal dump of heat that
just evacuated from the body.
Your core body temperature plummets,
and that's why you sleep better,
so you can hack the system very easily.
Wow.
So your core body temperature plummets
and that's what makes you sleep easier.
Yeah,
that sounds so counterintuitive,
but it makes sense and it makes sense
because that's how we were designed.
If you look at hunter gatherer tribes
whose way of life has not changed for
thousands of years in you,
how do they sleep?
One of the things that seems to dictate
the sleep is the rise and fall of
temperature.
Your temperature is at it's lowest in
the Nadeer of the night,
you know,
three or four in the morning.
And as that temperature that climate
temperature starts to drop,
that's when they start to get drowsy as
if temperature is just sort of signaling
to the brain.
Now it's time to sleep.
So light as well as temperature.
Uh,
two key triggers to help you get better
sleep.
If you look at those tribes,
by the way,
and when they go to sleep and they wake
up,
they go to sleep probably at two hours
after dusk,
sort of eight to nine in the evening,
wake up about half an hour or even an
hour before dawn.
It's the rise in temperature rather than
light.
That triggers their awakening.
But there's a reason,
you know,
have you ever thought about what the
term midnight actually means middle of
the night and that's what it should be
for all of us.
But in modernity we've been dislocated
from our natural rhythms and now
midnight has become the time when we
think I should check facebook last time,
you know,
I should send my last email.
That wasn't.
That is not how we were designed to
sleep and in fact we may also be
designed to sleep by physically too.
If you look at those hunter gatherers,
they don't sleep one long bout of eight
hours at night.
Yeah.
I've heard this recently that people
that you should have two sleeps.
The idea of two sleeps.
Yeah.
It's actually a little different than
the idea of to sleep,
so there was a time in sort of the
Dickensian era where people would sleep
for the first half of the night,
may be sort of four hours or so.
Then they would wake up,
they would socialize,
they would eat,
they would make love,
and then they would go back and have a
second sleep.
If you look at natural biological
rhythms in the brain and the body,
that doesn't really seem to be how we
were designed.
It certainly seems to be something that
we did in society,
but I think it's more of a societal
trend than it was a biological edict.
However,
we do seem to have to sleep periods the
way that we were designed.
Those tribes will often sleep about six
and a half hours,
seven hours of sleep at night,
and then especially in the summer,
they'll have that Siesta like behavior
in the afternoon and all of us have that
sort of this what's called the
postprandial dip in alertness just means
after lunch and if I measure your brain
wave activity with electrodes,
I can see a drop in your physiological
alertness somewhere between two to 4:00
PM in the afternoon,
but it's that dependent on diet.
It's not.
People think it is.
You know,
especially after they've had a heavy
lunch.
You can actually just have people fast
and sort of well fasting for long
periods of time actually makes you sleep
much worse,
but you can have people abstain from
lunch and you still get that drop,
so it's independent food.
It's a genetically hardwired,
preprogrammed drop that suggest we
should be sleeping by physically but
does is that dependent upon their
standard diet?
Because if,
if someone is on a carbohydrate,
carbohydrate,
rich diet,
a lot of times you do get that spike and
then you crash crash.
What?
When people are on low carb and high fat
diets,
they don't get that and they,
they,
they tend to be more even with their
energy through the day.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that sort of more constant release of
energy can actually help you sort of
almost combat that lo without lo exists
no matter what exactly.
So even if you don't think it exists,
it's there.
It's still present.
Interesting.
So why did they do that and then the
Dickens era,
why did they,
what is there a root cause of their
double sleep thing?
We don't know.
I mean,
it's hard to sort of really fascinating.
Yeah,
it's a,
a trend.
Yeah.
That it was a movement.
So they would just wake up and do things
and yeah,
maybe it's because they didn't have tv
and what to do with themselves.
Yeah,
sounds like they did some pretty
interesting things,
which are nice,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Well they created a lot of art then to
write a lot of writing and a lot of
fascinating stuff came out of that time.
Now when you're,
um,
when you're measuring a people's health
and when you're measuring people's
health in regard to how much sleep they
have,
like what,
how do you,
how do you do that?
Do you just talk to people?
Do you do surveys?
Like how do you get like a detailed
analysis of people's patterns so you can
do it at many different levels.
I mean we can start at the sort of gross
high level,
which is epidemiological studies across
millions of people where you do surveys,
you ask them about their sleep and then
you look at health outcomes.
The first thing from that data that's
clear is an unfortunate truth.
The shorter your sleep,
the shorter your life.
Well,
short sleep predict all caused
mortality,
which is really ironic because people
that want to sleep less.
I like,
you know,
I don't have a whole lot of time.
You know,
this life is short.
Yeah.
Fucking shorter if you sleep less.
That old maximum,
you know,
you can sleep when you're dead.
Yeah.
Well,
it's mortally and wise advice because we
know from the data you will be both dead
sooner and the quality of that now
shorter life will be significantly
worse.
Yeah.
That's counterintuitive to people.
The idea that you need this,
it's not just like you're making best
use of time by sleeping less,
you're not.
You'd make best use of time by being
awake less.
Exactly.
Which is crazy.
I mean wakefulness firstly from a brain
perspective is a low level of brain
damage.
We know that wakefulness is low.
Like right now where you and I are
getting low level brain damage.
Yeah,
that's right.
I need sleep.
That officer reparatory function.
Wow.
And,
and you know,
I'll give you one example,
which is your risk for Alzheimer's
disease,
insufficient sleep across the lifespan
now seems to be one of the most
significant lifestyle factors.
Determining
whether or not you'll develop
Alzheimer's,
what studies or if any have been done on
people that work third shift.
So people have looked at shift work in
general.
They haven't necessarily split it down
to that granular point,
but what we see is that shift workers
have higher rates of obesity,
high rates of diabetes,
but perhaps most frighteningly cancer
and in fact we now know the link between
a lack of sleep and cancer is quite
strong.
Insufficient sleep is linked to cancer
of the bowel,
cancer of the prostate,
cancer of the breast,
and the association has become so
powerful that recently the World Health
Organization decided to classify any
form of nighttime shift work as a
probable carcinogen.
Wow.
Yeah,
so jobs that may induce cancer because
of a disruption of your sleep wake
rhythms.
Are there other correlating factors like
don't people that sleep less or work
into the night,
don't they eat more,
more shitty food?
They do both of those things.
Yeah,
and we know exactly the pathway,
so there are two hormones that control
your appetite and your weight.
I'm one is called Leptin.
The other is called Ghrelin and they
sound like hobbits,
but
they're not the real.
They're real.
The real chemicals.
It's bizarre,
but 10
is the chemical that tells your brain
you're full,
you're satiated.
You don't want to eat anymore.
Grelin does the opposite.
It's the hunger hormone.
It says you want to eat more,
you're not satisfied with your food.
If I take people in,
these studies have been done.
We've done some of these studies too,
and you just put you a group of healthy
people on four or five hours of sleep
for let's see one week,
and you look at those two hormones.
They go and in fortunately opposite
directions,
so leptin that says you're full stop
eating.
That gets suppressed by lack of sleep.
Ghrelin,
the hunger hormone that gets ramped up.
So first the people who are sleeping
just five to six hours a night,
will on average eat somewhere between
200 to 300 extra calories each day
because of the under slept state.
Add that up.
It's about 70,000
extra calories a year.
It's about 10 to 15 pounds of obese mass
each year.
Which for me is starting to sound
familiar.
Um,
but what we also know is that it's not
just that when you're under slept,
you eat more,
you eat more of the wrong things.
So if these great scientific work,
if you give people this sort of finger
buffet and they can eat whatever they
want and it contains all of the
different food groups and you sleep
deprive them or you give them a full
eight hours of sleep,
yes,
they start to overeat by somewhere
around about 450 calories with total
sleep deprivation,
but what they go after is heavy hitting
carbohydrates and simple sugars,
processed food,
and they stay away from the healthy sort
of leafy Greens,
nuts,
proteins,
etc.
So you're not eating more,
you're eating more of the wrong things
and that's why a lack of sleep has such
a strong obesogenic profile to it and
you can take a step back to when you
say,
well,
if you look at the rise of obesity of
the past 70 years,
it's just this upward exponential
increase.
And if you plot on the Same graph,
the amount of sleep that society is
getting,
it goes in the opposite direction.
Asleep time is declined.
Obesity rates have increased.
I'm not going to sit here and tell you
that the obesity epidemic is simply a
sleep problem.
It's not,
it's a problem of as being sedentary
process foods,
larger food,
serving sizes.
If you take those factors though by
themselves,
they cannot explain the increase in
obesity.
Other things are at play.
Is sleep one of them now we know it is.
It's a critical factor in the
obesogenic,
a epidemic.
I know from personal experience when I'm
tired,
I always gravitate towards the worst
choices.
It's for me,
it's late night cheeseburgers,
wednesdays at 2:00
in the morning or whatever.
What happens if you get naps,
like save.
You only have five hours of sleep,
but you take a two hour nap during the
day.
Does everything make up?
Yes and no.
So what you're talking about there is
what we call prophylactic napping,
which has sort of strategically trying
to help combat your deficiency of sleep.
Naps can actually give you benefits.
we've done some of these studies where
they improve your learning,
your memory,
your alertness,
your concentration,
especially your emotional regulation to
sleep is critical for emotional first
aid and mental health.
However,
you can't keep using naps to self
medicate,
sort of short sleep.
Have you know,
four or five hours each night?
Um,
we know that the system itself,
your,
your brain has no capacity to regain all
of the sleep,
but it's lost.
It will try to sleep back some of that
debt.
But what we've discovered,
let's say I take you tonight,
I deprive you of sleep eight hours last,
then I give you all of the recovery
sleep that you want on a second,
third,
or fourth night.
you will sleep longer,
but you will only get back maybe just a
three or four hours of that lost total
eight.
So sleep is not like the bank.
You can't accumulate a debt and then
hope to pay it off at the weekend.
And so there is no credit system within
the brain for sleep.
You can't bank it,
which is odd by the way.
I would love that system,
you know?
Then you would know what road you would
know,
what you owed,
but I could also just know when I'm
going into a state of sleep debt and I
could build up some credit and there's
precedent for this.
By the way,
there is a system like that in the
brain,
it's called the fat cell because there
were times during our evolutionary past
where we faced famine and we faced feast
and so the body learned to adapt to that
and said,
when you have store it up as caloric
energy in these things called adipose
cells,
fat cells,
and then when you go into famine,
you can spend that caloric credit.
Where is that in the brain?
Why don't we have that?
The reason is very simple.
Human beings are the only species that
deliberately deprive themselves of sleep
for no apparent reason.
in other words,
mother nature has never faced the
challenge of coming up with a safety net
for lack of sleep.
We've never been forced to come up with
that solution.
That's why we get such demonstrably
disease,
sickness and impermanent.
When you undergo a lack of sleep.
So this is a recent occurrence and in
human beings,
is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
I mean the.
The only time we see it in nature is
when you go into conditions of
starvation.
The only way that you can get a species
to sleep less and it's very,
very difficult to do because sleep is
just so essential is when you put them
under conditions of extreme starvation
there,
they will forego some sleep to stay
awake so that they forage in a larger
sort of circumference area to try and
find more food.
It's probably the reason that when
people go into fasting there,
sleep is so terrible because the brain
is receiving this ancient trigger that
you're going without food.
You're in state of salvation.
You need to stay awake and hunt for
food.
That's why your sleep gets so much worse
when you're.
When you're undergoing fasting.
That's fascinating.
I did not know that.
So fasting is when you're talking about
multiple day fast and you're not
intermittent fasting and we don't know
the evidence for intimate and fasting.
So you know,
if some people are doing sort of 12
hours,
14 hours,
16 hours,
that that doesn't seem to be extreme
enough to trigger a change in sleep.
But if you fast for these long periods,
you know,
two days,
three days,
four days,
you can really see some quite marked
sleep fragmentation,
sleepest,
ask any of those people,
they'll tell you.
That's fascinating because people always
cite the health benefits of multiple day
fast.
Do you think that that's just like a
placebo effect?
Um,
I mean,
certainly we know that there are
chemical pathways that when you go into
fasting are activated that seem to be
beneficial for health outcomes.
There's a big literature on sort of
fasting and aging with the mtor pathway,
for example.
But you know,
we also know that as a species we're,
we were not designed to have such
terrible fragmented sleep.
And we spoke about how sleep regulates
your appetite.
You know,
if you're trying not to eat food and
sort of control and manage your weight,
the last thing that you probably want to
do is be shortchanging yourself on sleep
because it's only going to make you even
more hungry and reach for sort of worse
food.
So I still think there's room for
fasting in the equation,
but I think was extreme fasts and the
havoc that it plays on sleep,
it's still yet to be understood.
You've got to be very careful with
playing around with anything going
beyond sensible,
you know,
behavior.
So what does it like?
What is saved?
You're going to fast for two days.
What switches on that forces your body
into this haphazard sleep program.
So that's where that whole moon
gruelling just kicks into high gear.
That hormone that is just saying it's a
starvation hormone at that point.
It's not just a hunger hormone,
you've gone over into starvation and
that will promote a wa alertness.
It promotes chemicals that try to keep
you awake.
Chemicals like dopamine to sort of force
you wide awake.
So it's forcing you to go hunter gather.
That's right.
Yeah.
And this is even if your body goes into
a state of ketosis that we don't know,
people have not tried to correlate sort
of,
you know,
the profile change in ketosis versus
alterations in sleep.
I actually think it would be
fascinating,
you know,
maybe there's a peak where it's bad and
then you sort of,
you crest it and then things get better,
you know,
just the body acclimate to that.
I don't know,
it's w we've never seen the body being
able to sort of re engage with,
you know,
cognitive function with a dose of sleep
deprivation that keeps going.
So if I am,
it's the tcp intern,
take people and give them two weeks of
seven hours of sleep,
five hours of sleep,
three hours of sleep or no sleep,
you know,
even by sort of seven days or even 14
days of six hours of sleep,
your cognitive performance just
nosedives like a dart into the ground
and it doesn't show any signs of
leveling off as if there is no asymptote
that it could keep going.
And by the way,
people should know that after 20 hours
of being awake,
you are as impaired cognitively as you
would be if you were legally drunk.
Wow.
WhAt about physical movement?
Same thing.
Yeah.
Integrity of your alertness and reaction
time.
But it's worse.
And this is where,
you know,
drowsy driving comes in for every 30
seconds that we've been speaking,
there has been a car accident linked to
sleeplessness,
drowsy driving,
it seems kills more people on the roads
than either alcohol or drugs combined.
Whoa.
Why are.
Why are drowsy driving accident so
deathly rail?
Now I'm not endorsing those other
things.
Of course not,
but let's just think about why that's
the case.
When you're under slept,
you start to have what are called micro
sleeps.
Sometimes your eyelid does not close all
the way.
It just partially closes,
but the brain essentially goes to sleep
for just a very brief period of time.
You can even see individual brain cells
looks like they go to sleep during these
micro sleeps.
at that moment.
If you're traveling in a vehicle on the
freeway,
you've got a one ton misael traveling at
65 miles an hour and no one is in
control one time if you're lucky.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Last time you saw a 2000 pound car,
unless you have a miata.
Yeah.
Or yeah,
a mclaren p one.
But you know,
if you are,
even though they're having a are they
really shows my lack of knowledge
despite living with them.
You know,
I think what happens here is that when
with drugs and alcohol,
it's often the case of a problem of
later reaction with,
with a lack of sleep.
It's a problem of no reaction at all.
So you're out of it so you're out of it.
So rather than breaking too late,
there's just no breaking whatsoever.
That's my tip for people too.
If you find yourself cole or tired and
driving and you have to stay awake,
take a either ice or ice cold water and
put it in a wash cloth and then rub your
face with it.
It keeps you awake.
Works.
Yeah,
it works.
I mean,
if you're forced to drive for whatever
reason,
you have to,
you know,
you have 20 minutes to go and you're
really exhausted.
Do that,
I guess is the best.
Take a like a wet cloth.
Put ice inside of it and just rub your
face.
It just wakes you right up for whatever
reason.
And it's,
I mean,
those statistics around driving,
drowsy driving,
you know,
a frightening,
and it's a weird thing when you're on
the road,
you're,
there's something about those white
lines that just want to put you to
sleep.
There's no other time where I feel more
compelled to just conk out while I'm
awake.
Yet it's probably one of the greatest
sedatives known to men.
If that monotonous,
you know,
behavior.
And the longer you go with that
monotony,
the worst things get.
Um,
you know,
and if you look at,
um,
you know,
teenagers,
that's where we see some of the greatest
impact of drowsy driving.
You know,
it's the leading cause of death in most
first world nations.
Suicide is second.
Um,
wow.
ThAt is crazy.
It speaks to this,
you know,
this muddle of later school start times,
they've done these studies.
There was a great one that was done,
I think in tenent county in Wyoming.
They shifted their school start times
from 7:35
in the morning to 8:55
in the morning,
much more biologically reasonable
fatigue ages.
The only thing more impressive than the
extra hour of sleep that those teenagers
reported getting was the drop in vehicle
accidents.
There was a 70 percent reduction in car
crashes the following year when they
made that sentence zero,
zero search.
The advent of abs technology,
for example,
antilock brake systems that dropped
accident rates by 20 to 25 percent.
Some deemed it to be a revolution.
Here's a simple biological factor.
Sleep that will drop accident rates by
70 percent.
WOw.
So I think if our goal as educators
truly is to educate and we spoken about
learning and memory and not risk lives
in the process than we are failing our
children in the most spectacular manner
with this incessant model of early
school start times.
Why do we do that?
Or not just really school times but
early work times two.
I was driving to the airport the other
day at 6:00
AM,
6:00
bumper to bumper traffic on the four,
oh five.
I was like,
this is insane.
Look at these poor fucks.
What are we doing?
and if you're in the car at 6:00
AM there,
it means that you probably woke up,
you know,
five or 4:30
average school start times,
you know,
in the us,
some of them,
you know,
seven,
25 buses for school start time of seven,
25 will begin leaving at 5:30
in the morning.
That means that some kids are having to
wake up at five,
15,
5:00,
maybe even earlier.
It's just lunacy.
It is lunacy.
Now,
why did they do that?
I mean,
it's just a pattern that they've always
done and they don't,
they never corrected it again.
It's a pen that actually has,
has changed over the past 30 or 40
years.
I mean,
american schools used to go to.
I'm used to start around 9:00
and it started to shift ever and ever
earlier.
Why I'm part of it is because of work
times that parents had to get to work at
ever earlier.
Chart the kid.
Yeah.
And then bus unions and schools,
they comply to that same timeframe as
well.
And it becomes very difficult,
you know.
And um,
I don't mean to chest eyes,
school systems or the bus unions,
you know,
it's an incredibly difficult logistics
problem,
but I have to think that,
you know,
what is our goal here,
if our goal is to keep our kids safe and
to get them well educated and get
information into the brain and nurture
them and create them to be the next
generation early school,
start times on not the thing to do.
Um,
there's a lot of lazy kids out there.
They're going,
yes,
well pre john,
dr.
Preach.
I mean the data,
you know,
they looked at these academic things
too,
you know,
one of these,
another example comes from edina in
Minnesota and they shifted school start
times from a,
I think it was seven slash 25 to 8:30
in the morning and they looked at sat
scores and in the year before they made
the time to change the top 10 percent
performing students got an average sat
score of 1,288,
which is a great school.
The following year when they were going
to school now at 8:30
rather than 7:25,
the average sat score was 1,500.
That's a 212 point increase,
which is nontrivial.
Wow.
That's gigantic.
Yeah.
I just,
yeah.
I think it's the school time in
correlation with the work time.
Yeah.
It's very difficult to get people off of
that.
Yeah,
and that's part of what,
you know,
modernity has done where we're working
longer hours and also we're commuting
for longer durations of time,
so therefore people having to wake up
earlier,
they come home later and the one thing
that gets squeezed sort of like vice
grips is this thing called sleep,
you know,
and the decimation of sleep throughout
industrialized nations as a
consequences.
Having a catastrophic impact on our
health and our wellness and the safety
and the education of our children.
Silence.
Sleepless epidemic.
Wow.
Now,
other than I'm making the room cold and
warming up your hands and your feet and
things along those lines.
What about diet?
Is it or even time that you eat,
is there a specific time before you go
to bed that you should eat?
How much time should you give yourself
the digestive food?
So the general advice right now is don't
go to bed too full and don't go to bed
too hungry again,
if you're going to bed too hungry,
you can get that sort of,
that signal of I'm starting to go into
low level sort of starvation and that
can keep people awake at night.
Um,
the evIdence in terms of diet
composition and sleep is quite unclear.
It's not particularly well researched
area right now.
What we do know is that diets that are
high in sugar,
and I'm sort of heavier starchy
carbohydrates and low in fiber,
those diets tend not to be good for
sleep.
You tend to have less deep sleep and
your sleep is also more fragmented
throughout the night.
Um,
so that's sort of right now the best
advice.
So usually several hours before you go
to bed,
but not five hours.
That's right.
Yeah,
like two hours maybe.
And it's different for different people
and you will know it,
you know,
if you're sort of starting to wake up
with really severe hunger pangs.
What about supplements like melatonin
supplements or things along those lines?
Melatonin is efficacious.
It's useful when you're traveling
between time zones.
So at that point,
your body clock,
your internal clock is out of sync with
the actual real time in the new time
zone.
And let's say I fly from los angeles
over to london,
back home.
Um,
you know,
my melatonin spike is going to be eight
hours in the past,
you know,
sort of back in time.
It's not going to arrive with me for
eight hours.
So I can take some melatonin.
I can fool my brain into thinking,
oh my goodness,
it's actually dark when,
despite in California,
it's still daylight once I've arrived
through airport.
so you can use melatonin strategically
for jet lag once people however,
are stable in a new time zone,
melatonin does not seem to be
efficacious for helping sleep.
That said though,
if people out there taking melatonin and
they think it helps,
I would tell them to keep taking it
because the placebo effect is the most
reliable effecting all of pharmacology.
So if it works for you,
no harm,
no foul.
He taking it interesting.
So,
um,
the people that take melatonin nightly,
like this is what gets me to go to bed.
Really.
They're just playing a trick on their
mind.
Yeah.
Unless you're an older individual where
you're sort of 24 hour rhythm,
it's called your circadian rhythm starts
to get blunted in.
It's not as strong anymore.
That's where night nightly use of
melatonin actually has been demonstrated
to be efficacious.
But if you're young,
healthy and you're taking melatonin,
it's unlikely that it's actually helping
us sleep.
That's probably the placebo.
So it really should just be just for
traveling.
Yeah.
Or weird situations where your sleep is
interrupted.
That's right.
And you need to kick it into gear,
bring it back on.
So it's almost like a heck yeah,
it's definitely,
you know,
that's one way that you can check.
Like,
I mean,
there's no cure for jet lag,
but there's actually lots of ways that
you can hack jetlag.
Are there any other vitamins or
nutrients or particular foods that
enhanced the sleepy effect?
There was always thing about trip to
fan.
Everybody thought the trip to fan was in
Turkey.
What I read was that was bullshit and
what was really good
going on was that you just ate a
gigantic meal and it's filled with
stuffing and mashed potatoes and all
those carbohydrates.
Kashi
crash,
and it's usually the time.
Then everyone goes back through into
sort of the living room.
You lie down.
Most people are chronically sleep
deprived,
right?
Finally you get the opportunity to sort
of just relaxed and no one's doing
anything because there's no plans.
What do,
what do you think the numbers are?
Sleep deprived people in this country.
So we know those numbers.
Actually,
I'm almost one out of every two adults
in America and not getting the
recommended eight hours of sleep.
Almost one out of every three people
that you pass on the sleep,
uh,
on the street or trying to survive on
six hours of or less of sleep.
Um,
back in 1942,
gallup did a poll and what they found
was that the average american adult was
sleeping seven point nine hours of sleep
a night.
Now that number or most recently is down
to six hours and 31 minutes for the
average adult during the week in
America.
That's the average,
by the way,
that means that there's a huge swath of
people well below that average.
Now,
what about the people that say that they
sleep,
they go to bed,
they sleep five hours,
they wake up,
they feel great.
Yeah.
So bullshit.
Um,
we have the number of people who can
survive on six hours of sleep or less
without showing any impermanent,
rounded to a whole number and expressed
as a percent of the population is zero.
Wow.
Yeah.
Zero.
And one of the big problems with the
lack of sleep,
by the way,
is that you don't know your sleep
deprived when you're sleep deprived.
So your subjectIve sense of how well
you're doing with a lack of sleep is a
miserable predictor of objectively how
you're doing.
so it's like,
yeah,
especially.
Yeah.
Perfect example.
You know,
you're at the bar,
you've had six or seven.
I can drive home,
I'm fine.
And your response is,
I know that you think you'll find strive
subjectively objectively,
trust me you're not.
It's the same way with sleep
deprivation.
That's fascinating.
So,
but you're not drunk,
so even though you're impaired,
you don't feel like you're impaired and
you probably have a couple of espresso
or have one of these caveman coffee,
you feel fine,
right?
You get juiced up,
you're ready to go and you're trying to
accomplish things.
You're trying to succeed,
right?
You're trying to get ahead in his life.
I don't need to sleep.
And it's,
you know,
that's completely counter intuitive why
it's on the data.
We know that people are more productive
and they've.
We've seen some of these studies in the
workplace where you look firstly,
under slept employees will take on fewer
work challenges overall.
They ended up taking the the simple ones
like listening to voice messages rather
than actually digging into deep project
work.
They produce fewer creative solutions to
challenges that you give them.
They also slack off when they're working
in groups.
It's called social loafing,
where they just ride the coattails of
other people's hard work.
The less sleep that you have,
the more willing that you just sort of
don't pull your weight.
Furthermore,
it goes all the way up to the top,
so the moral,
less sleep that a business leader has
had from one night to the next,
the more or less charismatic that
employees will rate that business
leader.
Despite them knowing nothing about the
sleep of that ceo,
it's evident in their behavior more
because they're short with the,
you know,
they're,
they're short with their temper or
they're quicker to get upset about
things or less charismatic and social
with their conversations.
They're just,
okay,
I got it.
I gOt it.
I got it to work for.
Yeah.
I'm so less than does not equal more
productivity.
And it's always struck me as strange,
you know,
why do we sort of overvalue employees
that undervalue sleep and if you look at
your workforce,
you know,
trust me,
everyone's going to be looking busy,
but it's like stationary bikes,
everyone's looking like they're working
hard,
but there's no forward progress.
The scenery never changes.
That's what an under slept it workforce
will be for you.
Now,
what about the amount of time that
people spend at work?
I mean,
I know this is not related to to sleep,
but I've always felt like people weren't
too much.
I feel like you probably could get more
done with lesS time there.
Yeah.
So efficiency is what we're talking
about.
Again,
that's another one of those things with
sleep deprivation and I think many
people when they haven't had a good
nights of sleep that,
you know,
they're looking at this report and they
realized I've just read this paragraph
the third time and I still can't quite
get it as you had scrambled efficiency
productivity.
But I would feel like,
um,
when people are working eight hours a
day,
I don't think that you could work at
peak capacity for eight hours at least I
don't think the average person can and
you can't sustain that.
So you're,
you're kInd of bleeding these people.
You're getting blood out of a rock in
the last couple of hours and it's.
Yeah.
And it's not,
you know,
either a creative way to work in
creativity,
you know,
it's supposed to be the engine of know
business,
uh,
and ingenuity.
But why would you,
you know,
take twice the amount of time to boil
up,
you know,
a pot of water on half heat when you
could do it in half the time if you just
put it on high.
Well that sleep,
you know,
it's interesting though,
there are certain writers who use sleep
deprivation as a strategy for
creativity.
They literally don't start like the
writers for the sitcom I was on news
radio,
they wouldn't start writing until like
two,
three in the morning.
They would just play video games and
fuck around.
And then late at night they would really
start writing.
And they would ride until like seven in
the morning.
They would be,
they would stumble into the set like
barefoot delirious hair,
all fucked up with hilarious scripts.
And it's like they had used being silly
and overtired as a strategy almost like
they were doing drugs but they weren't
doing any drugs.
I mean it comes to,
well we didn't,
we don't know in that scenario,
you know,
it hasn't been sleep.
But what we have found,
at least in in our scientific studies,
is that that prefrontal cortex region
that we spoke about before,
that sort of rational,
logical part of the brain,
that's one of the first things to go
when you're sleep deprived.
So that area of the brain just gets sort
of switched off.
The more that you are sort of lacking in
your sleep and emotional deep emotional
centers of the brain,
which are normally controlled and kept
in check by that prefrontal cortex.
They just erupt In terms of their
activity.
So you're all emotional gas pedal in two
little regulatory control break,
which for the most part very bad.
But you know,
one possibility is that if you want to
try and get a little bit sort of,
you know,
crazy loosey goosey,
maybe that's not bad for that type of
sort of comedic writing that you know,
you become a bit more childlike and I
say that affectionately because the last
part of the brain to mature in
development is the prefrontal cortex.
So you revert back to almost a more
childlike state.
But I wouldn't,
I honestly would not condone that sort
of undergoing sleep just based on the
mortality and you know,
risk of alzheimer's and cancer by
itself.
You just don't want to keep.
Even in short doses,
like you're a couple days a week.
Like here's the,
if,
if sleep is not a renewable resource,
lIke what is the effect of say if you
have three nights a week where you sleep
eight hours and then the next night,
two hours,
and then the next night,
eight hours,
how much of a bump or how much of a dip
does that two hours give you and your
overall health?
It's bad,
it's bad.
So I'll give you two examples that there
was a study where they took individuals
and they just gave them four hours of
sleep for one night and what they saw
was a 70 percent reduction in critical
anticancer fighting immune cells called
natural killer cells.
These are wonderful immune assassins
that target malignant cells.
So today,
both you and I have produced cancer
cells in our body.
what prevents those cancer cells from
becoming the disease that we call cancer
is impart these natural killer cells and
after one night or four hours of sleep,
that is a remarkable state of immune
deficiency and that's one of the reasons
why insufficient sleep predicts cancer.
I could also speak about your
cardiovascular system though.
An all it takes is one hour because
there is a global experiment that's
performed on one point 6 billion people
across 70 countries twice a year and
it's called daylight savings time.
Now in the spring when we lose an hour
of sleep,
we see a subsequent 24 percent increase
in heart attacks.
What in the fall?
In the autumn,
when we gain an hour sleep,
there's a 21 percent decrease in heart
attacks,
so it's bi directional.
That's how fragile and vulnerable your
body is to even just the smallest
perturbation of sleep.
An hour one hour is insane.
Yeah.
wow.
That is.
You're blowing my fucking mind.
It's funny.
I mean you can go even further by the
way.
Wow.
Insufficient sleep will even erode the
very fabric of biological life itself.
Your dna code.
So In one study they took a group of
healthy adults and they limited them to
six hours of sleep for one week and they
compared to the profile of gene activity
relative to when those same people were
getting eight hours of sleep and there
were two critical results.
The first was that a sizable 711 genes
were distorted in their activity caused
by one week of six hours of sleep,
which is highly relevant by the way
because we know that many people are
trying to survive on six hours of sleep
during the week.
Wow.
The second.
Sorry.
No,
please go.
I was going to say the second sort of
perhaps more interesting result was that
about half of those genes we're actually
increasing their activity.
The other half were actually suppressed.
Those genes that were switched off by
six hours of sleep for one week.
What genes related to your immune
response?
Many of them.
So you become immune deficient.
Those genes that were increased or what
we call overexpressed with genes that
were related to the promotion of tumors,
genes that were related to longterm
chronic inflammation within the body and
genes that were associated with stress
and as a consequence,
cardiovascular disease.
This is unbelievable.
You know,
it's really disturbing to me.
I'm in my youth from age probably.
I guess I was probably 18 when I
started.
I delivered newspapers.
I used to drive around and throw
newspapers out of my car and I did it
for years and uh,
I would have to be up at 5:00
every morning and,
uh,
I never,
never went to bed early.
Yeah,
ever.
And I worked 365 days a year.
How old were you,
by the way?
I think I started when I was 18.
I might've been 17 whenever I started
driving.
Well I drove at 16,
but I don't think I started right away
delivering newspapers,
but it was trying to find a,
a good part time job.
I think I was either in my senior year
of high school or after I think right
after my senior year of high school,
so I was probably 18.
Okay.
And the reason I ask by the way is
because as you go through into their
sort of latest stages of adolescent
sensitive early adulthood,
your biological rhythm moves forWard in
time.
So you want to go to bed later and wake
up later.
so even if you went to bed sort of
conscientiously at that time,
at the seed,
like 10:00
or 9:00,
you wouldn't be able to sleep because
it's biologically impossible.
Yeah,
no,
I didn't sleep.
And then on saturday,
even worse one day a week,
saturday night,
I'd have to get up at three or four in
the morning because I had to deliver
sunday papers in the sunday.
Papers were enormous and so I had a pack
of van filled with site 350 people that
are delivered papers too,
so I'd have to do multiple trips so I'd
start work [inaudible].
I'd start delivering somewhere around
4:35
depending on when the paper's got in and
I was done by like nine,
nine,
30 and then I tried to crash,
but I was a wreck.
I mean,
and it,
it fucked me up for years.
For years I did that and I stop and
think about that.
Now I'm listening to you listening to
this conversation,
like what kind of fucking damaged that I
do to myself over those years.
Yeah.
I Will tell you about the stuff with
outside mr hannon,
lloyd protein and I feel okay now and
it's been.
It's been several decades.
Did I mentioned that your subjective
sense of how well you're doing with
insufficient sleep isn't.
No,
no.
Wow.
I'm sure you did.
And I'm sure that there's a factor
there.
Um,
what's stunning to me is that
sours is so detrimental.
I would've thought that had been fine
for six hours is good.
Like you get six hours ads.
Good.
That's normal for me.
Like six hours is normal.
Like literally the minimum is seven.
Yeah.
Seven to nine hours of sleep.
Seven you need anything under seven is
bullshit.
Yep.
for the,
for the average there is,
there is a small fraction of one percent
of the population that has a special
gene that allows them to survive on
about five hours of sleep.
Um,
and most people when I tell them this,
they say,
oh,
I have that.
I'm one of those people.
The chances of you being,
you know,
you're much more likely,
for example,
to be struck by lightning in your
lifetime,
the of which I think about one in
$12,500.
Then you also have this incredibly rare
gene that means you can survive on
something around five hours of sleep.
Really?
And what is the gene?
Well,
it's a gene that seems to promote sort
of,
again,
wakefulness,
chemistry within the brain that allows
you to sort of maintain wakefulness in a
more sustained way.
Um,
and so we're only trying to understand
right now what the actual biochemical
mechanisms are of in terms of the
consequences of that gene,
that gene mutation.
Um,
but certainly it seems to exist that
there are some of those,
quote unquote short sleepers by the way,
you know,
we hear if these business leaders,
and even actually heads of state,
I'm not going to name any names but I'll
give you right now,
but I'll give you two examples of the
past.
Margaret thatcher and ronald reagan both
were vociferouslY in the statement and
their declaration of how little sleep
that they would get.
Both of them said four or five hours a
night.
And I think in part it was to paint this
heroic ironclad status.
Um,
many people would say to me,
you don't know margaret thatcher
lifetime,
well,
sadly and tragically fascia and reagan
both ended up getting alzheimer's
disease.
You know,
and we now know because of its during
deep sleep at night that there is a
sewage system in the brain that kicks
into high gear.
And it cleanses the brain of all of the
metabolic toxins that have been built up
throughout the day.
This low level brain damage,
one of those toxic sticky proteins that
builds up whilst we're awake is called
beta amyloid beta amyloid is one of the
leading causes of underlying the
mechanism of alzheimer's disease.
So the less sleep that you're having
across the lifespan,
the more of that toxic amyloid is
building up night after night,
year after year.
And I don't think it's coincidental that
both of them ended up progressing into
tragically into a state of alzheimer's
disease.
So it's good night's sleep clean in that
way.
In terms of,
uh,
of deep sleep,
that's critical.
That is stunning.
Um,
are there anything,
is there anything you can do in terms of
how you eat or supplements you can take
that could potentially at least somewhat
mitigate the effects of having no sleep?
We haven't found any good counter
measures.
Have you tried diet pills?
So,
um,
people have tried things like a fog or
in the academy,
amphetamines,
you know,
I mean,
caffeine has been used strategically by
the military for years and caffeine can
help you get over the basic reduction in
your alertness.
So basic response times you can,
you can dose with caffeine and still
maintain some degree of a fast response
under conditions of sleep deprivation.
What about provigil or nuvigil?
You started modafinil is sort of the
underlying chemical there and debated
who actually came up with.
It may have been the french military who
actually ended up being the generators
of that.
That seems to work through a pathway,
at least right now as we understand it
for a chemical called dopamine,
and dopamine is principally known as
pleasure drug.
It's the chemical that a lot of drugs of
abuse will target to sort of ramp up,
but it also is a basic alertness drug
that when you get an increase in
dopamine,
you tend to actually get an increase in
your alertness and your wakefulness.
Don't you get an increase in happiness
as well?
You can too,
although modafinil tends to come with
the alertness component of that equation
and less so with the euphoria.
That's why it has a lower prevalence of
sort of addiction and abuse.
Well,
I know a lot of people who are,
I woulDn't say they abuse it,
but they say they have to use it.
Like all the doctor says,
the doctor says I got to use it.
I'm always suspicious because they seem
pretty normal other than the fact that
they,
they're exhausted if they don't take
this with what's essentially a
stimulant.
I've taken it a few times.
I've taken it when,
uh,
I have to drive like long periods of
time.
Like I'm driving from san diego to
California or to los angeles and maybe I
have a gig my gigs done at like 1130.
I know I'm going to be on the road late
at night.
I might take one and it's fine,
but it gives you this weird feeling.
It's a weird state and I know all.
Lot of tech people.
Yep.
A lot of silicon valley is on this stuff
and they pop it like candy.
So much so that tim ferriss,
when he was writing his book,
the four hour body,
he didn't want to include it and didn't
want include this particular drug
because he felt like people were just
going to eat it all the time.
Yeah,
I mean it's throughout student
populations.
Study drug as well as adderall.
Yeah.
As an adult,
you know,
and one of the interesting things is
that if you look at the,
the profile of what sleep deprivation is
cognitively,
you know,
reduced alertness,
impulsivity,
lack of ability to concentrate,
difficulties with learning and memory
difficulties with behavioral problems.
If I were to describe those features to
a pediatrician and say,
what disorder is this?
ProbablY say it's,
it's adhd,
yes,
but what we now know is that there is
some portion of children out there who
are diagnosed with adhd who either won
or just under slept or to actually have
sleep disordered breathing because of
perhaps tonsil problems where they're
not getting sufficient sleep.
And when you treat the Sleep disorder,
when you do a sort of,
you know,
remove the tonsils and they start
sleeping normally and the adhd
disappears.
So there is an issue here I think within
that sort of the explosion of adhd,
not all people are,
you know,
sort of privy to this sort of sleep
problem simply masquerading as adhd.
Some people are the,
one of the other problems too though,
is that adhd kids tend not to sleep very
well and what we ended up giving them is
a drug that is a stimulant which will
combat sleep and fight back against
sleep.
So I think we need to have a bit more of
a strategic approach is to when we think
about at least the dose of that
medication in terms of when sleep should
be x sort of expected during the day
because you know,
taking it in the middle of the day in
the evening or if it's a stimulant,
it's wake promoting drug need to be very
careful to sleep.
As part of that.
It was terrifying because I don't know
if the people that are prescribing these
things have the sort of deep education
and sleep and the necessity of it that
you do.
They don't and you know,
it's not their fault either.
You know.
In fact,
I've started to try and lobby doctors to
start prescribing sleep and don't make
the mistake that that's me suggesting,
you know,
prescribing sleeping pills that's a
separate,
straight sleeping pills are associated
with significantly higher risk of death
and cancer.
And I'm happy to speak about that too.
It was the one chapter in the book that
I think the,
um,
the legal team of my publisher took,
took a very long,
long look at.
But I think doctors come back to your
point,
they on average only have about two
hours of sleep education in the medical
curriculum.
So 1:32
hours,
two hours,
one third of this podcast has been two
hours.
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
Isn't that frightening?
That's terrifying.
And I bet you probably have laid things
out better in this podcast then you
would get in those two hours of
education.
I,
I don't know about that,
but I'll give you that credit if they
could,
if they could increase that,
you know,
I'm desperately appealing for this,
it's a third of their patient's life,
but they only get two hours of
education.
But the other problem is the medical
industry itself,
by the way,
you know that residents that data,
you know,
junior residents working a 30 hour shift
of 460 percent more likely to make
diagnostic errors in the intensive care
unit relative to when they're working 16
hours.
If you have elective surgery,
you should ask your surgeon how much
sleep they've had in the past 24 hours.
If they've had six hours of sleep or
less,
you have a 170 percent increased risk of
a major surgical error such as sort of
organ damage or hemorrhaging relative to
that same surgeon if they had been well
rested.
And then the irony here by the way,
is that when a resident finishes,
a 30 hour shift,
gets back into their car to drive home,
there is a 168 percent increase risk
that they will get into a car accident
because of the under state being ending
up back in the same emergency room where
they just came from.
but now as a patient from a car crash,
you know,
it's.
We need to radically rethink the
importance of sleep in education in,
in business,
in the workplace,
and in medicine too.
Why do they do that to residents?
It's a fascinating story.
Um,
so there's,
there's a chapter,
I'm in the book on this too.
It's a guy called william halsted and he
set up the first resident surgical
program in the United States at johns
hopkins university,
and he was known for being able to stay
awake for these heroic lengths of time,
days on end.
It was iNcredible,
like superhuman strength.
Turns out that in later years after he
died,
there was a dirty secret that he was
actually a cocaine addict,
that son of a bitch.
And here's what happened.
It wasn't his fault.
Yeah.
Alien is Korea.
He was examining the anesthetic
capacities of cocaine.
So,
you know,
if I'm not going to save,
you may have heard from a perhaps
colleagues that when you snort cocaine,
you get a numb face.
The reason is because it's,
it blocks nerves from colleagues.
My colleagues have told me I've actually
never done cocaine out of.
I've known quite a few people who have
and they will,
you know,
they'll have their sort of numbness.
It's the reason is because cocaine is
also a nerve blocking agents like
lighter cane lidacain.
Exactly.
Talked about this yesterday,
ironically on the podcast and about
doctors becoming drug addicts.
The initial doctor started doing
lidacain.
Hosted was he became an accidental
cocaine addict.
Wow.
And then for days and he was up for days
and he structured a program where he
expected his residence to match him to
go toe to toe with them.
But yeah,
it sounds like what a cokehead would do.
Come on and stay aWay.
Unbelievable.
And I think the story was that he
actually knew that there was a problem.
He went to rehabilitation,
checked in under a different surname and
one part of the regiment for him coming
off cocaine was to prescribe morphine.
And at the end of the rehabilitation
program he came out with both the
cocaine addiction and heroin addiction.
And so now there's rumors that he would
get his shirts laundered in paris,
in France,
and you know,
they would come back and it wasn't just
the white starched shirts that,
that were in the box that we were other
whites substances too.
But that's,
you know,
you ask a great question,
where did that come from?
Where's that history?
The legacy seems to date back to william
halsted,
who is an accidental cocaine addict.
And the,
we then maintained that inhumane
practice in medicine,
which is so critical to be awake and
aware and to be sharp.
You're cutting people open,
you're operating on people.
And think back to what we said about
being awake,
you know,
you would never accept treatment from a
doctor who started,
you know,
looking at your child who's sick with an
appendicitis at 3:00
AM in the morning,
who then switched some whiskey and says,
yeah,
I'm going to do the operations fine.
You would,
you'd go ballistic.
Well,
why do we accept treatment after 20
hours of being awake?
Your as empowered as you would be if you
were legally drunk.
So unfortunately we placed young
residents in this position of acting and
operating and decision making under
conditions of insufficient sleep.
One in five medical residents will make
a serious medical errors due to
insufficient sleep wanting 20 medical
residents will kill a patient because of
a fatigue related error.
One in 20.
That's crazy right now.
You know there are well over 20,000
medical residents.
If you have 100 of them.
Five were going to kill people.
Accidental deaths.
Think about that number.
That's insane.
If we were to solve the sleep loss
epidemic in medicine,
you know,
we could start saving lives and I don't
know what it is.
Is it just a,
you know,
an old boys network where we used to.
Well we went through it.
Yes.
So you've got to go through it,
you know,
and the data now is so prolific,
I write to all about that and try to
make a builder an evidence based,
you know,
emotional,
emotionless,
cold case for sleep in medicine,
asleep prescription for medicine as it
were.
Or most people don't realize the
requirements of residents have no.
And they are,
they are literally,
you know,
beyond human capacity thinking that
hubris and some degree of hours on the
job is going to be able to allow you to
sort of cut short what took three and a
half million years to sort of,
you know,
get in place which is an eight hour
night of sleep that's just thick headed,
you know,
it's,
and I think the medical profession,
it maybe at the stage where it's my mind
is made up.
Don't confuse me with the facts.
Wow.
That,
that this has blown me away.
I just don't understand how the very
people that are working on the health of
patients and fixing
them and repairing injuries and taking
care of diseases,
those are the people that are ignoring
one of the primary factors of disease
and errors and cognitive function
impairment.
It's a travesty.
I have a friend who's an ophthalmologist
and he tells a story about during his
residency,
he was,
is back in the eighties and he had a
pager.
He was on the toilet with a tray of food
on his lap because he didn't have time
to eat and go to the bathroom,
so it was eating food and he fell asleep
and then his pager went off and he's
like,
fuck my life.
How many warnings,
how many warning bells do you need to
tell you that you're in a military state
with your trousers around your ankles,
with food or via face,
and yet you're in the deepest stages of
non rem sleep and he's the guy who was
working on people's eyes.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
sleep is equally absent for the patient
in the hospital setting.
We know that somewhere between 50 to 70
percent of all icu alarms are either
unnecessary or ignore rubble,
know,
and the one place where you desperately
need the swiss army knife of health.
That is a good night of sleep is the one
place where you get at least,
which is on a hospital ward.
We could.
We could exit people out of hospital
beds earlier.
The data is already there.
For the neonatal intensive care unit,
they used to leave bright lights on 24
slash seven,
and that would prevent sort of the
signaling for sleep and wake and sleep
and wake,
and that cycle is critical if you
regularize sleep,
sorry.
If you regularize the light in the
neonatal intensive care unit,
those infants ended up having high
levels of oxygen saturation because they
were sleeping better,
their weight gain was dramatically
increased,
and they ended up exiting the neonatal
intensive care unit five weeks earlier.
Whoa,
simple things.
You know,
why don't we do something like this in
medicine?
When you come in onto a hospital ward,
you get this on an international flight,
travel for free,
earplugs,
facemask,
even just that by itself could help
people to start,
get better sleep.
Next on the hospital admission form,
tell me when you normally go to sleep
and when you normally wake up and to the
best of our ability,
we as doctors will try to sort of manage
your health care around your natural
sleep tendencies.
If we could do that,
you know,
sleep is is the elixir of life.
It is the most widely available
democratic and powerful healthcare
system I could ever possibly imagine.
Why aren't we leveraging that and taking
it?
That's one of the greatest hacks that
medicine could actually,
you know,
inflect a stunning.
How is this being received by doctors?
Are they reluctant to listen to you?
I mean,
what,
what is happening with all this data and
you're,
you're passionate cry for extra
sleep or more sleep or the proper sleep,
I should say it's starting to happen.
I mean,
when the book came out,
which is sort of the hub that came back,
I was in back in october and,
and some people started to give push
back sort of in the medicine realm.
You know,
there was some concerns about continuity
of care that if you keep switching
residents out every 16 hours,
that you wouldn't have continuous
patient care.
And tHat was a problem.
Um,
well there are other medical training
systems.
For example,
France,
Sweden,
New Zealand,
they do this all the time.
They do not allow their residents to
undergo anything along the,
neither of 14 or a 16 hour shift.
They train their residents in the same
amount of time or less,
and if you look at the rankings of their
medical health systems around the world,
they rank far higher than the United
States,
so you can't tell me that longer work
hours for residents,
for example,
unnecessary to train good doctors.
The evidence just isn't supportive,
so I've had some pushback there,
but for the most part I think people are
receptive once they know the information
and I think I'm the.
I've been someone who's been to blame
here.
I've known this evidence for,
you know,
I've been doing sleep research now for
20 or so years.
We are with sleep where we were with
smoking 50 years ago.
We had all of the evidence about the
deathly cost magenic cardiovascular
disease issues,
but the public had not been a word.
No one had adequately communicated the
science of smoking to the public.
The same I think is true for sleep right
now.
That's part of the motivation for why I
wrote the book,
why I've been doing or trying to do a
lot of publicity.
I'm a very shy person and I don't like
being in the spotlight,
but I feel as though there is a mission
that whose voice has not been actually
gifted yet and I wanted to try and help
him be a sort of asleep diplomat.
I mean that's why I chose the handle on
social media,
trying to be there as an ambassador for
sleep and now once people start to
understand the science as we've spoken
about for two hours,
then people start to actually realize
it's not the third pillar of good health
alongside diet and exercise.
It's the foundation on which those two
are the things said,
you know,
for example,
if you're dieting but you're not getting
sufficient sleep,
70 percent of all the weight that you
lose will come from lean body,
mass,
muscle and not fat.
Your body becomes stingy in giving up
its fat when it's under slept,
so once you get this information out
there,
things are starting to change.
I've started to have some discussions
with the world health organization.
They seem to be very interested now in
getting,
getting to grips with sleep.
I'd,
I'd love to speak to first world
governments tHere.
When was the last time you saw any first
world nation have a government supported
public health campaign around sleep?
I don't know any.
We've had them for drink driving for
risky behaviors,
for drugs,
for alcohol,
for healthy eating.
Sleep should be a part of that equation.
You know,
I want to lobby governments to start to
instigate this and it will save them
millions of dollars.
The rand corporation did an independent
survey two years ago on the demonstrably
cost of a lack of sleep to global
economies.
What they found was that a lack of sleep
cost most nations,
about two percent of their gdp,
the gross domestic product here in
America,
that number was $411,000,000,000
caused by insufficient sleep.
Solve the sleepless epidemic.
You could almost double the budget for
education and you could almost half the
deficit for healthcare.
Wow.
What studies,
if any,
have been done on people who live in the
northern hemisphere where they
experienced these long days like Alaska
and
places like that.
It's really tough for the regulation of
the circadian rhythm and what they.
A lot of people,
they're not all,
but a lot of people will suffer from
what's called seasonal affective
disorder,
which is the winter blues.
Yeah,
and you.
It's an unfortunate acronym.
Sad.
Dr.
Doctor comes along and you say,
look,
I'm not feeling good.
It's the wintertime.
Well,
you're sad.
No,
no,
I'm sorry.
It's a medical term.
It's got sad seasonal.
If it's called seasonal affective
disorder,
and that data is quite powerful too,
and you end up having to use melatonin
strategically to help you fall asleep to
sort of signal darkness in the
summertime when it's really liked or
almost all day and then in the
wintertime you reverse engineer the
trick and in the morning you sit and you
have your breakfast or you're working at
your terminal and you have one of these
big light boxes that sits next to you.
Strong looks power light to try and sort
of fool your brain into thinking that
you're getting a lot of daylight when
it's,
you know,
it's not going to be light for the next
four hours.
So they have to undergo treatment.
Do they have to do vitamin d
supplementation as well?
Some of that too.
Yeah.
BecaUse of lack of exposure for the
skin.
Why do uv light?
Listen man,
you,
I think you just open up a lot of
people's minds.
You certainly did mind.
You mean this podcast blew me away.
I thought I knew a little bit about
sleep.
I knew nothing.
Thank you so much.
Very welcome.
tell people how they could read your
book.
Where can they get it?
What's your website?
Yes.
So I'm all over social media and the web
pages.com
and the book is called why we sleep,
uh,
and it is out now on amazon and all
major book sellers and that's probably
the best way that they can learn all
about sleep and frightening the living
daylights.
Thank you so much matt.
I really,
really appreciate you last sleep.
Well,
thank you.
You too.
Thanks.